the Sirica combination of stuffy shadi
there's a farmer what mean should he
call you even somewhere hadith check our
sponsors and nature's blend they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sun now clearly chef
embarrassed by him Allah man
the silicon brother national stuffy
shadi there's a farmer warming should
eat Korean even somewhere had if God had
a had a boy in my no magic have a lot on
everything he died oh I know I had them
is a wife day for Heather hallander had
a nice ever feel an umbrella man that
they're alone in Kiran escalate when you
are religious and you're practicing if
you arrogantly think but for some reason
that you guided yourself Allah will no
doubt Lee let you know that he is the
one who's guided you and if needed he
will put you back into your miss
guidance and all the times we see our
sisters in the carbon hijab looking down
at our sisters who are not wearing the
hijab you know and sadly thinking that
practice in the religion is just a cloth
over the head or a neck up on the face
and this is a righteous act but to wear
hijab and in Aqaba brothers who wear the
foam and you know practicing their
religion looking down at those who may
not be doing or practicing just know
that yes they might be falling short in
the outer garments which they should
improve on but you are carrying an
arrogant traits and arrogant trade that
you're moving and behaving as if you
guided your very own self and that
guidance is in your hands what a big
mistake let's not forget before the
video starts that Shaitaan beliefs you
used to worship Allah everywhere he was
so righteous that he was at the ranks of
the Angels and how did he fall
how did he get misguided because he said
I am better than him miserable
feel an umbrella man at the Reno in
Kiran Haskell